hey you out come on now this is like a
jean tux it's amazing gentle cowboy I
had to show up real hard tonight not too
bad yourself over here thank you you're
bringing the color that's right
congratulations and everything thank you
you guys are opening the show we are
yeah what am I supposed to know that
right I know that right I think so I
don't think it's a secret anymore if it
is it's not anymore so I feel like you
got to get inside like prep and
everything uh I think we still got a few
minutes but maybe this should be our
last interview maybe we go now you know
what I was really doing I'm prevent you
from talking to anybody else no you
drink before the performance probably
have a couple sips little edge rock you
guys have done a lot of duets with some
pop stars pop stars find you guys very
popular and you've done quite
successfully with uh with those people
you're gonna do another one is there
somebody else here that you would like
to collaborate with tonight and maybe
showing up or somebody out there another
pop star I think we uh we've got a long
list of collaboration you know dreams
and bucket lists we just saw Khalid he's
he's one of our favorite artists that'd
be pretty cool outside the box
collaboration to do so we'll see what
happens we're gonna uh it feels good to
be here and kind of networking and
dreaming and thinking about what's next
but uh so you never know all right II
could be country who would be your dream
collaboration right now Alan Jackson
that is a boom mr. Jackson I was a baby
baby's great the baby is amazing life is
beautiful we got another on the way so
we're just steady growing is your your
baby ready for the other one coming on
the way I think so or uh we're preparing
Ursula see what are you doing to prepare
we're just talking about just talking
about the baby and you know Hayley's
always asking her what's that what's in
here you know and she says baby and just
kind of just uh whether or not she
really is aware of what's going on we'll
see when the
baby gets here but she's excited but the
baby gets here and the jealousy stars
that should might be over yeah
that's probably gonna happen well
congratulations and everything always
good to see you guys have a fun time
tonight
[Music]